[Music]
is
oh
[Music]
h
I
[Music]
is
a
[Music]
well hey you guys look it's just me and
as I promised I'm going to try to start
doing some live streams like live stream
my flickers of fear and TOS of Terror
stuff the way I had been doing you know
cuz I've been putting them up like
recorded and we thought maybe it would
be better to live stream them and kind
of do them at off times or like
different times than our regular show so
maybe we could pick up some viewers that
don't usually get to see the show live
maybe give them something to look at
kind of saves time for me too because I
don't have to edit all the videos which
is uh really nice now I realized as soon
as I sat down and started streaming that
I neglected to Port over my flickers of
fear intro like into my OBS on this
computer so I was going to use the movie
Time intro but I was like you know what
[__] it it doesn't matter you know what
I mean it's like it doesn't need an
intro we're just talking about a movie
and as I mentioned uh if you're on if
you saw like on our YouTube Community
tab um I announced that the first movie
that I was going to be reviewing was
this movie right here which is called
yellow brick road from
2010 uh because I was reminded of it
because I was flipping through tub the
other day sorry the noise you hear in
the background is Tom and his motorcycle
if you can hear that like cuz my office
as you guys probably know is right above
the garage and he got a new part for his
motorcycle so he's down there like
working on it and also getting ready for
Thanksgiving prep and stuff like that
too so I don't know if he's going to
wander in here at any point or whatever
but he didn't see this movie so he can't
talk about it but I was going through
tuby the other day and I saw that this
movie was on tuby I think it's on
Crackle too and maybe Plex but don't
hold me to that I'm not entirely sure
and I was reminded I was like oh my gosh
I saw that movie like a long time ago
and I remember really really liking it
and I don't really hear like a lot of
people talking about it so I said you
know what I'm going to rewatch it and
maybe review it and like you know give
it some love and see if like other
people like it as much as I liked it
before we get too much into that though
uh let me get into our uh affiliate
sponsor type of thing our 13:00
affiliate which on this show is going to
be audible now most people know what
audible is audible.com it's a subsidiary
of Amazon and you know one of the
world's largest if not the world's
largest uh repository of audiobooks
podcasts Anything Audio that you want to
listen to they've got it and uh there
are affiliate also I have a bunch of
books available on Audible as well so
and I read them myself uh True Crime uh
paranormal stuff horror novels horror
short stories all of my stuff is on
there so if you want to get a
subscription to Audible and listen to
them then you can uh of course do that
so what you need to do is you need to go
down in the description box and click
that affiliate link right there and if
you click that then you will get a
30-day free trial of audible uh so you
can listen to anything that's on there
for that 30 days and you also get one
free credit which you can use to
purchase anything on the site and that
is yours forever uh if you're already an
Amazon Prime member then you get two
credits and again you can use those and
keep whatever you buy with it so uh
again like full disclosure we are an
audible affiliate so when you click that
link and subscribe to audible then of
course we get a small commission but
yeah audible.com it's a really cool
service I use it and uh my books are
available on it as well so please click
the link and go
subscribe so okay so as I said I first
saw this movie back in I want to say it
was 2015 I'm pretty sure that's when I
saw it and I ended up seeing it because
and I'm sure I've mentioned this before
but I A lot of times I'll go cuz you
know a lot of horror movies come out
especially now now that the technology
is so cheap and everything so it's like
there's horror movies just all over the
place it's an embarrassment of riches
but the thing about it is that you kind
of need somebody to go through and like
curate the stuff because you don't know
I mean I I don't have enough time left
on Earth to like watch all of this stuff
and you know what if it's shitty and
what if you know what if I waste my time
and [__] like that so I kind of need
somebody to curate like what's good and
what's not so I ended up finding the
title of this movie back in 20
5 on one of those IMDb lists like
somebody had gone through and been like
these are the best horror movies from
this year and these are the best horror
movies from this year and this was one
of the ones that turned up on 2010 and
like the sentence about it sounded
really intriguing and then I saw that it
was on Hulu and so I watched it back
then and I was like wow that was
Dynamite I really really liked it and um
then like I said I feel like a lot of
people don't really talk about it and
then recently when I was scrolling
through tub like I said I saw it on
there again so I gave it a second watch
and liked it just as much the second
time and thought I would cover it just
in case because like I said a lot of
people don't seem to talk about it now I
will say this is one of those movies
like if you go on IMDb and maybe Rotten
Tomatoes but I'm not really sure what
it's what its rating is over on rot
Tomatoes not that that usually makes a
difference but I don't know I thought
this was kind of mystifying so on IMDb
this movie I think only has like a 2 and
a half star rating and that I don't know
if it confuses me necessarily
because this is one of those movies that
you're either really really going to dig
it and Vibe with it or you're really
really not going to so I'm going to say
if you're real into more like
traditional type horror like you know
super gory super action-packed stuff
like that you might not dig it this
isn't super experimental or anything
like that but it is kind
of cerebral I guess um has a little bit
of a surrealistic not I don't want to go
too far in that direction but it does
have a little a little bit of a surreal
psychological horror kind of thing um
almost abstract but not quite so um and
and I'm going to say too that it has a
very very ambiguous ending uh so if you
kind of just like horror that's all
wrapped up in the end or like youve
everything explained or something like
that then you probably will not like
this because it leaves a lot of
questions unanswered but I think that
was one of the things that I really
liked about it but I understand that
some people don't like that and hence
why this is kind of like in the middle
and it's weird because I read some
reviews from on IMDb IMDb like when this
came out and you know a lot of people
really dug it like I did but then the
people that hated it really hated it you
know what I mean I to me it doesn't seem
like that divisive a film but maybe I
don't know maybe it is maybe some people
just really really cannot stand like
ambiguity but you know what whatever
Different Strokes different folks I'm
not going to like [__] on other people's
tastes in horror movies because that's
like a stupid thing to do so
basically um what this movie is about
this was actually the first the um
directorial debut of Jesse Holland and
Andy Mitten now I believe this movie was
made for only
500,000 um that's at least what I heard
that's it doesn't say on Wikipedia but I
found that somewhere else I don't know
if that's accurate um you know obviously
5 $500,000 is a lot of money but not for
making a movie um so and I think they
did a really good job like within the
budget hi Richard Brown what's going on
uh little bit of cosmic horror yeah this
definitely does have a little bit not so
much like in a lovecraftian kind of
thing but just in the sense
that I don't know like I said it leaves
it ambiguous and it's like forces larger
than us that are like doing things for
their own um Amusement maybe or
something but they don't really explain
like what that is so like I said if you
don't like [__] not explained then uh
then this might not be for you I will
note that this movie did win uh best
film at the New York City horror film
film festival in 2010 like when it came
out so some people did recognize that it
was cool but like I said a lot of people
that reviewed it really really didn't
seem to like it but then the people that
really liked it really liked it and
actually if you look I can't remember
what the name of it was but if you just
search yellow brick road and it's all
one word like it's all run together um
review I think it comes up on like the
first or second page of Google somebody
wrote this really long really um
articulate essay like about the themes
of this movie
so I mean I really liked it like I read
it a couple times and I'm just like wow
so it has like a big long analysis it
kind of invites that sort of analysis I
guess which I like that kind of movie
but you know like I said some people
don't so and and like I said I think the
main criticisms that people had about
this movie was that they thought it
wasn't gory or scary enough which fair
enough um it's not real gory but I will
note that one scene in particular
particular if you've seen the movie then
you probably know what I'm talking about
um is pretty [__] up and I thought it
was much more affecting for being
unexpected you know what I mean because
if you have a movie that's just kind of
like wall to--all Gore and violence and
stuff you kind of get inor to it like
after a while so it's not as shocking
this movie I will say like when that
scene happened the first time I saw it
like my [__] jaw dropped I was like
holy [__] [__] cuz I was like totally
not expecting that to happen and it just
kind of comes not necessarily out of
nowhere there is like a little bit of a
buildup but I wasn't expecting it to go
that extreme like that far but it's not
like wall to Wal gor like I said but
there are strategic moments of violence
that are very very shocking for being
unexpected like I said which I think I
liked about that and a lot of people
like I said didn't like the ending so if
you don't like ambiguous endings like I
said then you're not going to probably
dig this either so um so what okay so
what this movie is about I don't know if
I necessarily well I don't know I I
don't even know if you can kind of spoil
this movie because it's so because the
premise is so weird but you know I'm G
just try to discuss it like as far as
that goes um now I have seen this movie
compared to the Blair Witch Project
which sort of just in the sense of
people getting lost in the woods and
getting disoriented and them there being
like some unseen force or something
that's kind of like after them but I
think that's kind of as far as that
comparison goes this isn't found footage
uh necessarily it does have a little bit
of a found footage thing because you
know sometimes the you know there's a
psychiatrist on the mission and he's
like filming them and stuff so that is
sort of found footy but generally it's
not a found footage movie um I've but
honestly I've also seen it compared to
session n which I think is kind of a
better comparison it's nothing like the
you know plot-wise or anything like that
isn't like that but just like the vibe
that it gave me and the way it made me
feel was kind of similar to the way
Session 9 like made me feel you know
what I mean so it's kind of in the same
it's the same Vibe it doesn't really
have anything to do with what the movies
are about or anything also want to say
it had a slight slight little bit of a
David Lynch um type of vibe to it too
and I'm saying that there's that garage
door um and I'm saying that mainly
because the sound design is a big part
of the horror in this um and also this
uses uh The Wizard of Oz like as a con
like through line like a referent um
kind of like what David Lynch did in
Wild at Heart but this isn't funny you
know what I mean like and that was kind
of funny I need to review Wild at Heart
one of these days now that I'm thinking
about it because I don't think I've ever
reviewed that and I love that movie but
yeah so so it does have like a an
overlay of Wizard of Oz to it and like I
said there's a lot of sound that factors
into the plot so I think that's kind of
what reminded me of David Lynch but I'm
just really I don't remember who it was
that I saw compared this to Session 9
but I was like oh that was like a pretty
I probably would have never made that
connection but the vibe of this is kind
of similar to session n at least in my
opinion that's you know so I thought
that was a pretty astute
observation yeah it's a deep booming
they came and the weird like music and
stuff like that that's coming out and
there's the weird like retro record
scratch kind of noises and stuff and
it's just coming out of nowhere and they
don't know where it's coming from so the
plot of this movie basically what
happens and what you see in the in the
in the um opening credits is that back
in 19 40 there's a little town called
frier New
Hampshire and in 1940
inexplicably almost all I believe almost
all of the residents of the
town they went to their little movie
theater and they watched The Wizard of
ozs which was like their favorite movie
they'd seen it like so much that they
said like the the um film was like in
tatters because they'd watched it so
many times they just watched it over and
over and so they go in there they
watched the movie and then they all went
home put on like all their Sunday best
clothes like they all suits and dresses
and everything like that gathered up all
their like record albums and some of the
crank um you know record players and
wandered off into the woods for no
reason now later on they did recover
some of the bodies I think like half of
them were never found like half of the
people were never found but then the
other half of the people they either
found them like frozen to death or like
you know Dead from the elements or they
found them like horribly mutilated and
murdered and like ripped apart and [__]
like that and they have no [__] idea
what the hell went on out
there so this is like a mystery that's
persisted since 1940 about this town and
it's kind of become um something of like
a like a
Legend So after that's established we
have the main character
who are like a husband and wife team
named Teddy and Melissa Barnes and
they're filmmakers like he's a
photographer and I guess she's some kind
of folklorist or something like that and
they're collaborating they want to
collaborate on a book about this mystery
and they're also bringing along a friend
of theirs whose name is Walter who's
like a psychiatrist and he's going to be
there to keep track of everyone's mental
state like during the during the trip or
whatever so they get the this grant to
do this what they're planning on doing
because they got all of this information
about the town which apparently was like
really hard to get so they got all this
information and they're going to go to
frier New Hampshire and they're going to
follow the same Trail because they want
to find out what the [__] happened to
these people um because no one has been
able to figure it out like it's a total
mystery so they kind of okay so they get
together this team so they have their
friend the psychiatrist like I said they
have I think it's like a brother and
sister and they're like map makers you
know they you know they hike trails and
like make maps and stuff uh they have an
intern and then they have um another guy
I can't remember oh I think the other
guy is like a survivalist type of dude
like he goes like camping or whatever so
he like knows all about that kind of
stuff and was that it I want to say that
was it oh and then when they get to
frier New Hampshire they had the GPS
coordinates for the trail head like the
trail where the towns people like set
out from but when they get to the town
they find out that the coordinates lead
them to the movie theater which is the
last place where all of the towns people
were before they took off into the woods
and they're like well okay that doesn't
make any sense so now they kind of get
disappointed they're like we came all
this way and it's like now we don't know
where the trail head is because
obviously it's not the movie theater so
they're in there and everybody in town
like the few remaining people who are
you know obviously younger now and [__]
because I guess people moved back in or
these are like the relatives of people
that wandered off into the woods or
whatever but it's still like a really
small town so everyone is like really
hostile towards them nobody wants to
talk about it nobody wants to talk to
them and they don't like that they're
there like I think even before they go
like they get all these phone calls it's
like don't come here and like all this
other kind of [__] because everyone just
wants to kind of forget about it and so
so the guy at the the kid who's working
in the movie theater he's just like are
you guys like [__] or something it's
like this is obviously a movie theater
and not a trail head like get out of
here like you have to pay to go to a
movie or whatever but then there's
another girl like a young woman and she
works there and she's like back at the
like popcorn like the concession stand
and she's kind of like going like hey
you know come here you know what I mean
and so Teddy goes back there like he
pays to get in the other ones go outside
and he go he goes in there and she's
like yeah I know where the trail head is
it's like my grandfather used to come
here all the time and he told me about
it so she's like so I can show you where
it is but you have to take me with you
she doesn't seem let's let's put it this
way she seems like a like a nice enough
person but she doesn't seem entirely
stable however she does have all of this
information and so Teddy is kind of
obliged I guess to like let her go along
even though it seems like it's probably
like against his better judgment right
so she goes along with the team so they
find the trail head and the reason that
this movie is called yellow brick road
is obviously because of the whole Wizard
of Oz uh you know thing that they're
doing but also because at the beginning
of the trail head which they eventually
do find there's this kind of rock and it
has yellow brick road like inscribed
into it and that's where the trail head
is so they set out now as you might
imagine because this is a horror movie
[__] starts getting weird kind of
quickly like At first it's just kind of
like yeah it's we're following the trail
and everything seems kind of
normal the first kind of [__] that
happens though is that they start
getting weird like readings on their GPS
and they start like kind of getting lost
like for a while cuz the the intern girl
she's the one with the GPS and she
starts making jokes about oh this says
we're in like Melbourne Australia and
it's like you know now we're in Florence
Italy and it's like you know they're
kind of like joking about it but then
like the brother and sister who along
with them who are map makers they're
kind of getting a lot of screwy uh sort
of readings like on their surveying
equipment and stuff like that and
they're like we have no idea what's
going on so as they kind of get deeper
and deeper along the trail like weirder
[__] starts happening like one of the
things that starts happening and like I
said this is going back to the kind of
sound design thing that I was talking
about earlier was that they start
hearing like this old timey like
1940s music like coming from somewhere
like it sounds like it's coming from
like a record and it's really spooky and
it seems like it's coming from the sky
or coming from like some distance and
they can't tell where it's coming from
so they're hearing all of that and
they're also hearing like a bunch of
weird noises like booming noises or like
record scratch type noises or that's
kind of driving them slowly crazy and
the psychiatrist as he's going along
like I said he's got a videotape and
he's his whole task because they were
kind of afraid they didn't know like how
long this Trek was going to take and
like if there was some kind of danger as
far as you know the people that wandered
off in the woods if there was something
weird going on out there so they wanted
to bring him along to make sure that
everybody was like staying mentally
stable like while they were on the trip
and so um so he so periodically like
throughout like while they're going on
the trip he's like filming like just
asking him to like to do like what what
do you associate with um what smell do
you associate with the color red like
things like that so he's just trying to
like determine that like nothing's going
on but as time goes on like they start
giving weirder and weirder answers and
the people start getting like more and
more unhinged a little bit um but in
different ways I think it kind of like
depends on who they were to start with
um as far as like how their mental state
starts to deteriorate you know what I
mean it's not the same for every single
person um but as they go on it's just
they just start doing crazier and
crazier [__] um it seems like they're
getting these weird coordinates that
makes it seem like they're spiraling
inward towards something and they can't
figure out like I said where all this
noises coming from and [__] like that
and then [__] gets like more and more
horrific like as time goes on so that's
so like I said I don't want to spoil too
much of it and I don't want to spoil the
ending um because the ending I feel
like was left open to interpretation and
that's why there's been like some kind
of you know I would want to say kind of
scholarly analysis like about this movie
because it does kind of invite that um
at least the way it ends and especially
because it's so closely linked with
Wizard of Oz
I definitely think there's some kind of
thematic uh resonance like some kind of
point that they were trying to make
there I have some theories about it but
I'm not really sure if I'm correct um I
actually really liked the ending but if
you like I said if you want something
like really explain to you and [__] then
you're not going to be a happy camper
because this explains pretty much
absolutely nothing and like Richard um
I'm glad you brought up the cosmic
horror thing because I might not have
phrased it like that but now that you
mention it it is kind of like a little
bit of a cosmic horror story because you
never do find
out what like why why these people
suddenly wandered off like what is that
in the woods that's luring them there
because it does essentially seem to be
luring them and so and then they get
there and then like they start going
crazy or they start killing each other
or something like that but you don't
really know what the forces that's doing
it is this a being of some kind is it
just some weird like anomaly that's not
intelligent like they don't really tell
you but like I said I think I like that
better because and I've said this before
lots of times too I prefer it in horror
where you don't OV explain to me it's
like much scarier if you don't explain
[__] like if you don't give it any
context give it a little bit of context
just so you can get like a slight handle
on it but the more you explain it the
less scary it is and so the reason that
I think this movie was real creepy to me
and stuck with me after all these years
cuz like I said I saw it like a long
time ago and you know wanted to revisit
it because I remember liking it so much
was I don't know there was just
something about it that was like really
got under my skin yeah Picnic at Hanging
Rock yeah that's another good that's
another good comparison that's another
good comparison where they just kind of
leave everything see to me that's scary
because picnic and Hanging Rock to me is
like one of the creepiest movies ever
made because nothing is explained you
never find out what happened never and
you don't in this one either but that's
okay like I said to me that's scarier
because then it gets your imagination
working you know what I mean and I think
that's what that's what horror should do
so so yeah I mean if you're a fan of
kind of like real smart or like subtle
horror um I think you might really dig
this and like I said if you like stuff
like session n or Picnic at Hanging Rock
or like I said it this gets compared to
the Blair Witch Project a lot but I
don't I can see where they're coming
from with that but the vibe of this is
different to me there's like something
different going on in this one that's
not really going on in The Blair Witch
Project I like The Blair Witch Project
I'm not saying that but I think this is
a different kind of movie there are some
surface similarities but I don't think
like the similarities are in
particularly in depth um but yeah I
really I really liked um the shot
compositions in this uh I really like
the
editing and there's just through the
whole movie there's just this real just
very palpable sense of like Dread and
unease you never really know because you
never know what's going on they don't
know what's going on
um and and you're kind of put in the
same boat as them uh you're just as
disoriented as they are and to me that
made it like really really
frightening uh Commander says uh I love
this movie I did too I I just thought
this was so great and like I said I
don't hear a lot of people talking about
it and this is actually you know for
this review this is my second time
seeing it because I saw it the first
time back in 2015 and I just remembered
really liking it like it really stuck
with me and um and I and now that I
rewatched it a second time I can really
see why I
can't I can't say that I have any new
theories about about it but again that's
okay because I like everything that's um
that's kind of ambiguous and subtle like
this I like too which I guess this is
kind of different to Blair Witch Project
too but I like that most of the horror
in this takes place in the daytime in
broad daylight I like that because some
horror movies and I'm not saying like
dark isn't scary like night time
obviously it is that's why a lot of
horror movies are set at night or in the
dark or in the shadows or whatever but I
always admire a horror movie that can
scare you and not use that as something
to lean on which this one didn't I don't
know there wasn't really much scary [__]
in this that happened at night there was
a couple things but I think most of the
scary [__] that happened this was like
in the daytime CU obviously they were
traveling during the daytime so a lot of
the creepy [__] took place in daylight
so so I like that because that's much
harder it's much harder to make a horror
movie that's scary that's almost all in
the daytime like you haven't you don't
have like [__] popping out of the dark
or anything like that which like I said
yeah I get that it's
scary but um but it just I don't know
the tension in this really really well
done like the the whole time you're
watching it you just feel like really
uncomfortable and like kind of
off-kilter like I said because you don't
really entirely know what's going on and
you're just kind of on edge the whole
time because you're just like well this
could just go any Direction and like all
the characters are getting more and more
disoriented and you don't know what
they're going to do like are they going
to flip out or you know you don't know
what's going on they don't know what's
going on and I really like that so this
whole sense of like displacement and it
just keeps like escalating like as the
story goes on and it's kind of like
paralleling the character's mental
States as they're just like losing their
Marbles and not really knowing what's
happening so I think that's great uh
Richard Brown said did they make any
more films I looked it up they don't a
Wikipedia page or anything like that I
think this might be their only one at
some which is really a shame because
this was a really good movie and I
thought that because it it you know
because it won an award back in 2010 I
thought maybe that would kind of like
launch them into something but it really
doesn't seem to have um I'll have to
look it up but I didn't really see
anything else other than maybe I think
they maybe made some short films but I'm
not really sure about that but I'd have
to like look it up another thing I liked
about this too was that all of the
character characters were all pretty
likable like some of them were kind of
douchy or whatever but not like I don't
know I see a lot of horror movies where
like the characters are just like oh my
God I just want to punch all these
people in the face these people seemed
these people just seemed like regular
people you know what I mean they weren't
like over the top or anything and the
characterization in this is really good
too because I feel like you get to know
the characters like there's not a lot of
exposition there's not a lot of oh let's
all sit around the campfire and tell our
tragic Back stories or anything like
that like you kind of just get to know
them in the field like just the way they
react to things and like little offhand
comments they make and stuff like that
so it's
very um they use like really brief
Strokes to kind of get you in the head
space of each character and it's really
efficient like I thought it was like
officially done which again is a really
hard thing to do because you see in a
lot of movies like where you have you
have to explain that this character is
like this and it's just goes on too long
so it's a lot quick you know it's a lot
better if a filmmaker can get a
character and you just like you know
they just have a couple of lines and
some body language and stuff and you
know what that character is all about
and I think that's good this movie is
good at doing that um there are like I
said this there are some kind of funny
moments in this um you know particularly
I kind of laughed when they when the GPS
first starts to go and this is before
anything goes super super bad so the GPS
starts going [__] up and like starts
telling them they're like in all these
different crazy uh places like around
the world where they obviously aren't um
but at first kind of the only thing
that's going wrong so they just kind of
think it's hilarious so they're just
like making jokes about it's like oh
where are we now it's like oh we're in
Florence Italy and then they all start
speaking Italian and stuff like that so
it's like so it has funny moments like
that but the funny moments don't they
seem like organic just like coming out
of the characters like that's what would
really happen like if you were out in
the woods and that started to happen you
would just make jokes about it it
doesn't seem like it like the humor is
just like shoehorned in to release the
tension or whatever which is another
thing that you know kind of bothers me
in horror movies at least if it's like
really obviously done I don't mind humor
in horror movies I don't and I like
horror comedies too but sometimes you
see in horror movies like it's like oh
we got to throw in something funny to
like release the tension from the scary
scenes it's like you don't necessarily
have to do that but I think that it was
well done here because it didn't
seem affected you know what I mean it
just seemed like it was just a natural
outgrowth of the characters which I
liked you know it seemed spontaneous um
and as I mentioned earlier very little
VI and Gore however um there is one
scene in particular that just kind of
comes a little bit out of nowhere or at
least is a lot more extreme or a lot
more shocking than you would expect like
given how the movie has been going up to
this point and the first time I saw this
movie I was just kind of like holy [__]
like I was not expecting it at all so I
think that the fact that this movie is
as far as violence and Gore goes is
really restrained and I think that
really helped it because the couple
times when something violent and gory
does happen then you're just kind of
like holy [__] crap like it's super
super shocking so I think they did like
a really good job um doing that too
because it really like shakes you up you
know what I mean you're not expecting it
because that wasn't the way you thought
the movie was going to go because it's
been pretty subtle like up to now now um
so again like again other other than
like all of the other things that I've
just talked about that I really liked
about this movie I think one of the
things I liked best about this movie was
maybe the thing that cus the most
contention um among the people that
really didn't like it like over on IMDb
uh which again was its ambiguity they
never tell you how much of this journey
is real um how much is you know in the
character's Minds like how much is this
reality is it a mass hallucination
perhaps did they even go there um you
know is this some kind of Supernatural
Force whether intelligent or not that's
like leading these characters to their
Destinies perhaps or maybe is it
something inside themselves that's you
know leading them toward their own
destruction like they brought it on
themselves maybe and they kind of leave
it open for sort of like either
interpretation you know what I mean like
you're led to believe that it's
something Supernatural because there are
apparently things happening like outside
like I said you do hear the music like
off in the distance they all hear it and
like the the sounds and stuff and you
know it is true that their GPS is messed
up and their you know map coordinates
are coming out all screwy and stuff like
that and they can't find their way back
cuz they seem to be spiraling towards
something or other that they can't
figure out what it is um so but but you
could like I said kind of read it each
way especially because each character
kind of loses their marbles like in a
specific way that has to do with their
character you know what I mean um and
like I said this is kind of Where The
Wizard of Oz
touchstones um are really relevant
because I mean the whole theme of The
Wizard of Oz is you know Journey ends
where it began you know what I mean it's
just kind of like Dorothy she gets
carried away to this Fantastical land
but then through all of her adventures
there she learns that well my happiness
was right here like back home so I think
that that really kind of ties into the
theme of this as well but this movie not
like Wizard of Oz cuz Wizard of Oz had
kind of like a happy ending this one is
kind of like the dark side of Wizard of
Oz because this one I read it as almost
kind of like nihilistic you know what I
mean because pretty much I mean pretty
much everybody dies almost and uh the
one character that
survives they kind of manage to get back
to the trail head but then once they get
there it's like nothing's the same you
know what I mean and like I said that's
as much as I want to say cuz I don't
want to spoil it if anybody hasn't seen
it but it's just like I I don't know
it's it's really hard to describe um
Richard says I've heard people describe
this one as lovecraftian do you agree I
don't know if I'd go so far as to say
lovecraftian because I think that I
don't know I I think that lovecraftian
and Cosmic horror are used like
interchangeably but I don't necessarily
think they're the same I think love
crafty and horror is like a subset of
cosmic horror I would call this Cosmic
horror I don't know if I'd call it love
crafty and horror because I think that
has a different connotation I think
people when you say love crafty and they
think oh like Elder gods and like
tentacles and [__] like that which this
it could be that
but I I don't know I just kind of read
this one as like I don't even know if
the force that's luring the people into
the woods if that's what it is I don't
even know if it's necessarily
intelligent and if it's not that kind of
makes it scarier I don't know why that
is you know what I mean like I don't
even know if it's a being it might just
be like a force of nature that's like
not even trying to do anything it's just
these Woods are just like that and so
people are just lured in there like
because of their own whatever and it's
just like to me that's kind of a scarier
concept but like I said you could read
it either way it could absolutely be
like a being out
there uh DVD Dragon says tell Tom his
motorcycle noise increased my
testosterone level I will be sure to
tell him that yeah he's he's been
working on it down thing like I said I'm
not really sure like how much of it you
can hear like in this microphone because
it seems when I'm recording in the
garage door goes up or down or like his
motorcycle it's like really really loud
and like I usually have to take it out
because it sounds loud to me but yeah
but yeah so um let's see I've been on
for like 40 minutes so I might have to
like wrap this up because I have a
appointment uh in a little bit but as I
said if you're real
into like a kind of cosmic horror but
like kind of realist like psychological
horror type of thing then you might
really dig this if you haven't seen it
and at the moment it's on tub at least
as of when I'm streaming this which is a
couple days before Thanksgiving of
2023 and it's absolutely worth watching
if you like those kind of like creepy
ambiguous kind of movies like that and I
feel like it doesn't get a lot of love I
feel like it sort of like fell between
the cracks a little bit which is kind of
a shame cuz it's really good and it's
one that really stuck with me like the
first time that I saw it and really made
me want to rewatch it when I saw it like
come up again so yeah so if you haven't
seen it like I said go over to tub and
watch it it seems like um you know
people in the chat have seen it um
because and they liked it as much as I
did which is good because like I said I
read a lot of read a lot of bad reviews
of it and I was just kind of like I
don't get it but whatever um but yeah
and also if you look up and I wish I
could remember the name of it but there
was a really good essay about this movie
um and I think it was called the end of
the path or the end of the road or
something like that but it's like if you
just search yellow brick road all in
word and then review like it should come
up um have I seen the endless yeah and
actually you know what I should review
that one too because I I think that's
due for a rewatch I saw
that probably five years ago now I want
to say maybe more I don't remember what
that came out what year did that come
out 2013 2014 or was it more recent I
saw it a few years ago and then for
whatever reason I didn't review it but I
was thinking about it the other day
because I saw it come up on one of my
streaming services and I was just like
oh yeah [__] I should totally I should
totally talk about that one too maybe I
should do like a whole Cosmic horror
thing you know what I mean because I
really like that kind of because that
because that definitely that's
definitely Cosmic horror I can't
remember if if I would call it overtly
lovecraftian but it's definitely Cosmic
horror like I said this one I don't
think I'd call it lovecraftian but I
would definitely call it Cosmic and it's
definitely kind of surreal too but not
so much that it's that you can't tell
what's going on you know what I mean
it's just kind of like leaves a lot of
questions unanswered which I know a lot
of people don't like but I like it but
yeah so I guess I'm going to wrap this
up remember to uh click the link in the
description box down there for a free
30-day trial of audible uh cuz I get a
commission from that link when you click
on it and subscribe and I will see you
guys again tomorrow for our main show
Tom will be back for that obviously and
we're going to be talking about analog
horror back rooms Lial spaces all that
kind of stuff so that should be like a
really fun creepy entertaining show and
of course if you're in the US that's the
that's Thanksgiving Eve so we've already
started doing Thanksgiving preparations
cuz you know you know how we do it's
like we make so much food and it just
takes us weeks and weeks to eat it all
because you you know how that rolls but
yeah all right so I'm going to wrap it
up I will see you guys later thank you
you guys for dropping by I might be back
um I might do another one of these on
Friday and it'll probably be a book
review but it might be like a short
story novela situation because I don't
have a lot of time this week but I might
be doing um the pram by Joe Hill which
if if you have um Sorry my phone's
ringing if you have Kindle unlimited um
you can read it for free on there I
think it's only 60 Pages or something
like that so I'm going to read that over
the next couple days and I'll probably
come back on maybe Friday sometime to
review it um I'll let you know like what
around what time it'll be or something
like that or if I have to move it to
another day because I might have to but
yeah so thanks for dropping by everybody
and I'll see you guys again tomorrow
good night